a man to my right the sports columnist
from the Los Angeles Times after ten
years
it's a senior writer at ESPN arash
mikaze here on the Rich Eisen show now
with the LA Times good to see you sir
thanks for having thanks for having
thanks for being here I I was gonna ask
the question myself but I figure I
should have I should have Stephen a do
it right Stephen they do it Chris I
[Laughter]
think we knew who magic was referring to
when he was talking about whispering and
backstabbing I was really shocked though
that he went into specifics about what
Rob did and the first thing that I kept
thinking was magic has said that he
wants to still help this team in some
capacity in fact he told us that
yesterday in a separate conversation
I don't know how Rob palinka is gonna
now get on a phone or sit in front of
you go through the names Kevin Durant
Kawhi Leonard
Kyrie he basically said this man is not
to be trusted he said that he sabotage
him that he backstabbed him how is Rob's
pálinka supposed to bring in the next
superstar that's gonna help this team
out I have no idea how cuz we had c-webb
Chris Webber on the show in the first
hour and if his thought process is
indicative of what other star athletes
in the NBA think of magic and view magic
and viewed what magic had to say
yesterday is the prevailing wisdom yeah
then that's gonna be a very difficult
sell for polenka he see what basically
said magic was truth-telling yesterday
yeah I attempted to say to him hey look
to me it sounded like a different story
from the bizarre press conference that
he held in an impromptu manner on the
last day of the season you were there I
imagine Rob kind of confirmed what magic
said in terms of not always telling the
truth Rob can't just say listen we have
a great relationship some of the best
years of my life love life for the last
two years with magic clearly there's
something there so he almost by taking
the high road him by the way he's not
gonna win that PR war right he's not
gonna beat Magic Johnson in a PR war but
you have to at least concede that it was
a strained
relationship it's a little you know
you're not doing yourself much favors by
saying listen I love magic we talk all
the time we'll grab food soon or
something it's not by the way it's not
their fault they were put in this
position by Genie buzz who does deserve
some blame for putting two people
together who had never worked with each
other they don't know one another and
they've never run a team before and so
she kind of put two people together who
didn't really know how to do their job
so that's your your headline today Genie
bus needs to play a bigger role in
Lakers reality show right now the
reality is this it's May 21st 2019 July
1 2019 directly around the corner I mean
we are five six weeks away there's a
general manager who you pointed out was
just absolutely what's the word for
clowned denuded whatever you want walt
or neutered by Magic Johnson on ESPN
First Take yesterday to the point of the
detriment of the rest of the free agent
class coming I said yesterday and I'm
wondering what you think feel free to
disagree on don't need to have have
anything echoed back is that the only I
can fix this is LeBron LeBron James on
the guy who can go to every single one
of those stars that you mentioned we're
good here he's the only one that could
basically go to Jeannie and say we've
got to do this we've got to do that yeah
he's the one that can go in front of a
microphone whether it's on the shop on
HBO whatever what he was there yesterday
rich when I saw him I said maybe this
might be the one silver lining the one
bright spot to this day that LeBron will
come in and kind of vouch and give some
support to Frank Vogel give some support
to Rob Lincoln he did not did not at
least publicly we have not seen him
since he was shut down for the season so
much in terms of a microphone and
traditional media settings he has he has
his phone in his hand anytime he wants
to yeah I mean he could send out a tweet
if he wants to he's not yet he has the
shop he could do it on the shop again if
if he can lend some credibility to
what's happening with the team that
would go a long way he has not done that
excel is I don't think he likes what's
happening with the team I don't think
they hired the coach that he wanted them
to hire which was hot I Lou I I don't
think he likes the current strong
structure
I think Magic Johnson was a reason he
came here now at the end of the day I
think he wanted to come to Los Angeles
it wasn't so much because of the team I
think he wanted to come here he's got
his companies here he's got his homes
here he wants to live here that's why I
don't think he's gonna chase a
championship in Toronto or someplace
else but I don't think he likes what's
happening I think he's gonna make the
most of it cuz when I hear stories about
them wanting to trade LeBron and LeBron
wanting to be traded that's not true
that they will not trade LeBron and
LeBron does not want to be traded what
the broad doesn't want I imagine is the
conversation of the final act of his
career being he was in a spot just for
his next businesses and it was really
neither here nor there for him if you
wanted to win a championship I agree and
I think that's why he's got to do what
you've suggested is basically be a more
commanding presence in calling these
guys now whether that's Kyrie Irving or
someone else I don't think they're in
the running for KD I don't think they're
in the running for Kawhi but maybe it's
Kyrie maybe it's someone else but he has
got to kind of really be a more
assertive figure in this and maybe he is
behind the scenes certainly in front of
the camera he has not been that guy well
your colleague Arash mikaze here at the
LA Times bill Pulaski said in your
newspaper today that his body language
and yesterday's press conference looked
like a guy who's been was checked out
yeah that's what he said it's hard to
say when when someone doesn't talk to
you you can only go off of what he's
doing and so he's in the back drinking a
cup of water or a coffee he's playing
hoops he's talking to his friends and
you know he doesn't have to talk to us
but I think it would have went a long
way to Salus and I like Frank Vogel he's
a good man I think there's a good hire
rich I don't think he's saying that
because he doesn't believe it maybe just
yet and by the way he thought ty lue was
gonna be the coach and ty lue did think
he was gonna be the coach so what he
thought was gonna pan out has not yet so
let's get into that here
why isn't Tyler with the coach here I
listen I think ty lue is a very proud
man he thought he deserved five years
deserved that commitment
if the Lakers only offered him three
yeah they're basically saying to him we
want you here just for LeBron yeah we do
not believe in you as a Laker coach post
LeBron we don't believe in you as the
guy who can bridge post LeBron to the
next era with whatever championship
quality we build we don't we need to we
need to wait and see on that we know
what you can do with LeBron we need to
wait and see what you can do it I don't
blame him for basically saying pound
cent but then I can also see polenka if
he is in the realm that magic says that
he is which he he views things in terms
of leverage or not he might be a
leverage junkie trust me I've come
across a ton of those in my air of the
business of negotiating contracts in the
on air portion of my life
I mean he's where else you gonna find
five years standpoint was you're not
even being talked to and he actually is
not he's not in the ruin the
conversation for a job right now that
being said as you mentioned he was
already gonna be perceived as LeBrons
guys so at least give me a four or five
year deal where you're not aligning my
contract for LeBrons got two years left
or three years left that's your your
contract the issue was Tyler was the
perfect coach for this team I mean he's
someone that LeBron likes and respects
and has a track record with but here's
what I don't get the reason the magic
and Rob dynamic did not work you put two
people together who've never worked
together have no loyalty now you've done
that with the coaching staff you brought
in Jason Kidd a man who wanted the job
very publicly wanted that job and you
forced him upon Frank Vogel who I
actually think is a good coach and has a
chance for success but he's walking in
and his successor is right next to him
it made no sense it doesn't make much
sense
let's hit the couple things that don't
make any sense one by one then and just
parse it out arash mark Ozzy of the Los
Angeles Times here on the Rich Eisen
show so they made a decision or palinka
made a decision that got the check mark
from Jeannie boss one would assume of of
prioritizing leverage over what's best
for love LeBron Lakers yeah by saying
the tyloo were you getting five years
from you don't have any leverage where
his leverage is like mom right for the
right I'm the right guy for the right
job right now
and LeBron wants me and that wasn't
viewed as more important than having the
leverage of giving him a three-year
contract trying to squeeze too few years
out of him if I'm LeBron I'm sitting
there going what the hell is that
exactly and by the way he wasn't only
LeBrons guy bill Jackson said that to
the right guy for the job
Magic Johnson if you care what he says
felt that was the right guy for the job
and so so why did he not get hard then
because they don't believe that LeBron
does palinka deep down think that that
that it's a power struggle between him
and LeBron there or or they just did not
love tyloo as much as LeBron did and
Phil Jackson does that you would lose
this man because of one or two more
years this is a four billion dollar
franchise I mean like who cares if it's
one or two more years but they I think
that they were still shocked that Tyler
walked away from the deal because they
were saying where are you getting this
offer from and I think he was just proud
and finally you go down to the list of
guys Luke Walton preferred Sacramento
Monty Williams preferred Phoenix
tyloo preferred his couch I mean that
that's the state of the franchise right
now that you would prefer Sacramento you
would prefer Phoenix and you would
prefer your couch I mean that's where
the Lakers all right now and then so
then the other thing that doesn't make
sense that you pointed out is Vogel
having Jason Kidd on the bench where
they I guess they split it they split
the they gave one guy the head coaching
role and the other guy is the okay this
is for you LeBron roll that's the
problem here I mean you're putting him
together with the man that LeBron has a
relationship with they were teammates on
Team USA they won gold together they're
friends if LeBron has a problem or you
know he wants to talk something yeah
he's probably gonna go to Jason Kidd
first and Jason Kidd already has a track
record of trying to kind of sabotage
people or try to backstab people to get
his way maybe that's why Rob Lincoln
I'm not sure but why they were insistent
upon putting him with Frank Vogel if you
like Jason kids so much higher Jason kid
in fact that dinant that dynamic may
have had a chance Jason Kidd head coach
Frank Vogel as his lead you know number
two lieutenant Jason Kidd's not gonna be
a lieutenant Jason Kidd wants to be the
captain of the team well then before we
send you back down the Imperial Highway
for the Los Angeles Times I mean you
could walk it's remarkable the loss and
we're talking about walking distance for
anything in Los Angeles or something
Arash mikaze here on the show all right
we were talking yes cuz this does sound
like Game of Thrones and obviously
you've got Thrones on the brain since it
was just 48 hours removed Brockman said
yesterday who has the ability then which
character is the one that can breathe
fire on MAGIX statue and melt it like
the throne and del Tufo in a remarkable
moment it was like Costanza spottin
dimes in the floor said Kobe
what role does yet does he have any or
is he literally making just in charge of
his own II got campaign that I'm sure
he's gonna actually succeed it's very
coaching his daughter I mean what where
does he stand with all this I don't
think Kobe wants a day-to-day
responsibility but the only reason Rob
pálinka has the job he has is because of
Kobe Bryant and I think that's we need
to hear from Jeanie buss we need to hear
from certain people I want to hear from
Kobe Bryant at some point because again
Rob link is in the position he's in
because of Kobe what does Kobe's
thoughts about this what does Kobe's
thoughts about what Magic Johnson just
said about his friend it's very unique
in the soap opera for this team I mean
amazing that were we're in the
Conference Finals and the most
fascinating story is with the Los
Angelos they are I mean there are
Tiffany franchises in all of sports not
I'm not just talking about the NA I mean
you want to talk about an international
brand that magic said he would buy if
the phone rang was that on to you to
that
yes point-blank if you a family not for
sale but I don't think magic would have
a hard time putting together the
guggenheim group for example to purchase
them again I think what Jeannie has to
do is bring in each someone who has a
track record for success of running a
team Rob link has never run a team Magic
Johnson's never run a team Tim Harris
Linda Rambis you go down these are all
fine people they've never run a team
before so when you go back to dr. Jerry
Buss he entrusted G Jerry West to run
the team and you go across the street or
across town and the Clippers and you got
Steve Ballmer and you got Jerry West and
you got Doc Rivers if you're a player
and as someone who grew up in Los
Angeles I cannot believe the signature
franchise you would want to go to is now
the Los Angeles Clippers well they're
the ones that in the playoffs they're
the ones with a coach of the Year
candidate they're the ones with also a
contract that's open do you think that
that's more attractive to koalas you
said it's not coming to Lakers he's not
coming to the Lakers because he's either
staying or going to the Clippers and I
think the Clippers may be in the running
for keyd so then you look at the top two
guys KD and Kawhi if they're gonna come
to Los Angeles is with the Clippers not
with the Lakers I guess I'm coming full
circle here I still think that Katie's
not going anywhere
I don't think why would he leave a
situation don't you think that like if
they if they run the table which they
they've won six straight without him I'm
sure does that I think that makes you
feel like man I kind of have to go
somewhere else to prove myself no I
think I think that they could win it
with you know they can win ten games
without me I I was obviously a key
component to winning the first
back-to-back that they've now won a
third part of it was me getting them to
the 2 to the 1 seed in the West part of
it was me getting to the point of a game
five against the Rockets point of it is
me is I love these guys and they love me
I love that new arena that's being
opened up they're gonna open up my heart
they're they're their treasure in hearts
I love living in the Bay Area why the
hell would I want to go down and the
Clippers and try and start something new
or go to the Knicks I mean you got to be
kidding me that's the way I'm right and
klay Thompson is the best example of
that where he's from Los Angeles his dad
works for the team there is no chance
he's leaving that he loves the Warriors
and his dad has even told him do not
leave can't just to bring it all again
full circle button it up here if I'm
LeBron and I see okay
Kobe's got his guy is the general
manager and and I can't get my guys the
coach and I'm on the team and Kobe's
down in Orange County coaching his
daughter and winning he gots you know
I'd be I'd be sitting there staring at
the at the wall first split second and I
know he is right now but he was upset if
this everything I've just said into this
microphone is an accurate total 100
percent what is happening portrayal of
what's going on down the street ask
Arash the poll question before we we
send him back to yeah Roger the end of
EP the playoffs so far Yanis Kawhi Stef
draymond oh that's a tough one I would
say Kawhi just because I don't even know
if that team wins the series without him
I just think in that first try and I
always thought he would come to Los
Angeles but that last-second
series-clinching shot if he stays is
because of that shot thanks for coming
in whatever what's the results as they
currently stand
Steph 39% dreamin 24% for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app